after another week of searching crime
and Anarchy across America president
Trump tearing into Democrat run cities
and vowing to stop leftist mobs these
cities it's like living in hell Chicago
is an example it's like worse than
Afghanistan they're anarchists the big
thing they want is they want to really
destabilize our country and we don't let
them they've created bedlam they've
destroyed very important things I mean
you're also talking about statues of
George Washington Abraham Lincoln they'd
like to get Jesus we're gonna get
tougher and tougher and at some point
there's gonna be retribution because
there has to be these people of vandals
but they're agitated but they're really
it terrorists in a sense the president
isn't the only one fed up with what
we've been seeing a Chicago activist
calling out black lives matter for not
focusing enough on the gun violence
plaguing his community the entire nation
should be outraged when a three-year-old
is executed on the streets of Chicago
and a thirteen year old young young girl
was killed on the west side Chicago as
well it makes no sense to me if we can
see you to stand up against the system
but we will not stand up in our own
neighborhood meanwhile sleep with Joe
Biden under fire from the left for not
embracing the radical defund the police
movement political insiders are worried
the Democrat base will reject Biden if
he doesn't get on board all right Greg
what did you think about the president
using the phrase terrorists when talking
about the agitators and the looters I
don't know I mean I I I don't think
words are enough anymore I think that
there needs to be some kind of action
and I'm not sure what it is but that
what I find interesting is the gun
violence in Chicago is a reality what
you're seeing going on in America is a
racial hysteria so why is one gaining
attention and the other isn't and I
believe that the worst thing a black
community can do as a whole is take
advice from coddled white
over-caffeinated overeducated under
experienced left-wing individuals
because look at the consequences the
black on black crime or the gang
violence and the gun violence ignore
but everybody's running around tearing
down statues so I want to end the race
war that we seem to be experiencing
today I'm gonna blow your mind with this
okay there are more differences and
conflict within white then there are
between whites and blacks there are more
conflicts and differences between whites
than there are between whites and blacks
when you look at those pasty white wimps
out there running around vandalizing and
destroying property I realize that I
have absolutely nothing in common with
these laughable losers and in fact when
anybody looks at the TV they realize
they have no nothing in common as a
white person with these failures so it's
insulting to me and it should be
insulting to every white person that you
are you think that race binds us it
doesn't bind us I have more in common
with black winners than white losers and
that's the truth of all human beings we
have a weak what ties us together is
achievement and not grievance so white
winners and black winners are on the
same side and stay away from the white
losers because they are poisoning the
minds of everybody that will end racism
if all the winners of every race and
color join together and laugh at the
losers yeah I like that idea
why Williams we talked about it
yesterday BT founder saying that a lot
of black Americans just laugh at these
as Greg would say pasty white losers
tearing down statues and canceling TV
shows because they think you know that
that doesn't mean much well I'm here to
defend my white brothers I think this I
think what's going on here is President
Trump is desperate his poll numbers have
cratered and when he was asked last
night on Sean Hannity's town hall
meeting you know what's coming next
what's your message what's your agenda
he really didn't have much to say since
he's experienced he's great everything
will be great so what he does Jesse as
he takes a few instances of looting or
bad behavior and he blows it up suddenly
cities are war zones Afghanistan
suddenly these people are terrorists
they're so powerful they're threatening
our socials fabric I mean the reality is
that his message I think if you live in
Minneapolis Minnesota you'd probably
agree that it did let me just say
because everything's on fire and it cost
a billion dollars in damage now look
that you you can keep showing the same
footage again and again and again but
here's let me just say it's real trust
me on this don't trust me listen to the
Wall Street Journal in their lead
editorial this morning they said Trump
is headed for a historic loss as
millions of Americans are close to
saying that they can't risk four more
years of this they can't stand it
they're talking about suburban nights
they're talking about women they're even
talking about seniors abandoning Trump
and I think that's why he's engaged in
this kind of horrible imagery and
language because he doesn't have a
message he didn't he's not killing
people in Chicago he's not looting one
these things are actually real they're
not fantasies true he could do a better
job he could do a better job facing
these problems we agree with that but
you can't lay those problems on him as
somehow he's conjuring this stuff up in
order to win an election this stuff is
real people are suffering wad they're
suffering in Chicago they're suffering
in Minneapolis they're suffering in New
York they're suffering in Atlanta
they're suffering in Dallas or suffering
in California and you go isolated
incidents wake up one you got to wake up
to this and start it started helping
your party face the truth well I think
the truth is we've had black on black
crime in this country for a long time
and I think the incumbent is Donald
Trump if he was about healing
reconciliation if he was doing something
to deal with those problems maybe he'd
have a better case maybe he'd have
something to say about bringing
Americans together but he doesn't have
anything less reason to
the president has to a police reform and
the Democrats rejected it and he's
offered him to help with the National
Guard and you guys attacked them for me
all right Emily what did you think about
Greg's idea about the winners getting
together against the losers that were
you did that provoke thought in your
mind yeah I'd like to be on the winning
team as always
I'll weigh in though on this larger
conversation this is absolutely the
Democrats blaming America for the
problems that they have caused the
reason that they want to make it about
federal reform or federal action is
because it makes it the country's
problem not theirs but the country
didn't cause these problems their
policies did so when we talked about
Chicago and the fact that this month
they had the most violent and deadly
weekend and day in their 60 years of
keeping track of violence that is the
predictable result to the multi-factor
rot under democratic policies horrible
public schools and excessive poverty the
inability to break out of dependency
programs cycles the food insecurity all
of those things that is because of
Democratic policy and it has festered
all of those factors under the decisions
that these Democratic local and state
leaders have been making and when they
sit around and say Oh America needs to
change it's because they are deflecting
away from the fact that their policies
need to change you guys know I'm a
Californian I was in junior high in the
Richmond Public Unified School District
in 1990 when in the middle of the year
it went bankrupt and you know what
happened after that
the predominantly black city of Richmond
had that credit rating affected because
of the bankruptcy and the entire school
district changed its name because of
that and that kind of systemic rot
that's the tip of the iceberg of
democratic policy rot but at that time
that's one school district that got
bailed out by already bankrupt
California now every year there's about
50 that is the rot I'm talking about it
and it's Democratic policies so Dana how
does the president match up against
Democrat mayors and governors it's the
similar thing to what we had with kovat
19 were kind of brawling with with Cuomo
and stuff and now he's brawling with
Democrat mayors and governors over the
Rye
in the end the chaos does that work for
him politically in your opinion well
with some people yes but let's take
Michigan for an example obviously he has
had a little bit of a tussle with the
governor there governor Whitmer she was
not necessarily covered in glory herself
but recently if you see the feedback
from Michiganders a significant portion
of them felt that the president was
singling them out and being mean to them
for political reasons rather than on the
merits not saying that that's true I'm
just saying that's how they felt so I
don't know politically if that's
necessarily working but one thing that
the president can do and he's shown he's
willing to do this before he can convene
a meeting he's really good at that
and he's not ideological so he's like
he'll meet with anybody he'll listen so
instead of I mean I think he should call
out the local governments we're not
doing enough but I also feel like that
call out should come with some reaching
out and what if he called up mayor
Lightfoot and said I'd you got a problem
I'm here to help what do you need from
me how can I help you I asked you what
do you have to in 2016 I said what do
you have to lose Here I am I'm here I'm
we're willing to spend money look at all
the money we're spending lots of money
on coronavirus response I'm willing to
help you on the security front I think
the people of Chicago deserve better
they need to be protected and safe and
if you need federal government help I'm
here to help you what would it take and
if she does not take him up on it then
you can go more political that's just an
idea